bonsoir voila vous êtes donc à rotterdam
quelle est l'atmosphère sur place
quelles sont les mesures prises par les
autorités néerlandaises
eh bien écoutez
pour l'instant c'est plutôt calme même
s'il est difficile de dire si cela va
continuer puisque est les émeutiers
organisent leur rassemblement de manière
sporadique il est donc compliqué de
savoir où ils vont être à l'avant c'est
d'ailleurs peuvent éclater à tout moment
ici à rotterdam plusieurs magasins ont
été vandalisés voire incendié et après
les affrontements qu'il ya eu la semaine
dernière et ces derniers jours elle est
mère de plusieurs villes ont pris des
mesures d'urgence a par exemple ici à
retorde à mons trouve actuellement le
maire de la ville
ahmed abou taleb a mis en place un
décret qui autorise la police à
renforcer et à multiplier les
arrestations il faut savoir que ces
émeutiers bien il s'organise tout
d'abord dans un premier temps sur elle
et réseaux sociaux
et puis d'après les médias néerlandais
la plupart seraient de jeunes
adolescents certains seraient des ferait
partie de groupes d'extrême droite et
d'autres seraient des corona sceptiques
le gouvernement néerlandais a promis de
son côté de sévir et a dit je ne
s'inclinera pas devant ce qu'il a
qualifié de la racaille ou et des
criminels il faut dire que le pays n'est
pas forcément habitué à ces débordements
à ce genre d'affrontement d'ailleurs
nous avons pu parler à quelques
policiers qui nous confiait bien que
c'était la première fois qu'ils avaient
à gérer ce genre de situation et la
classe politique prend ce problème très
au sérieux
le premier ministre mark rutte a déclaré
qu'il s'agissait des pires émeutes en 40
ans
de son côté le sud le nationaliste git
wild horse a quant à lui appelé l'armée
à intervenir une proposition et qui a
été rejetée par le premier ministre mark
rutte
selon le maire de rotterdam plusieurs
suspects qui ont été arrêtés seront
présentés dès demain devant la justice
plusieurs centaines de personnes ont
déjà été arrêtées ces derniers jours
et si cette soirée elle semble plutôt
calme pour l'instant
des races
ble ment sont organisés et prévus samedi
et dimanche merci monard ou dès lors en
direct donc de rotterdam